c'est désormais officiel devant les élus
du Bundestag Olaf scholls le confirme
l'Allemagne va bien fournir des chars
léopards de temps réclamés par son allié
ukrainien
nous allons livrer à l'Ukraine des chars
de type léopard 2 cette décision est le
résultat de concertation intense avec
nos alliés et nos partenaires
internationaux je veux souligner que
cette décision est juste nous ne nous
sommes pas laissés entraîner
dans un premier temps Berlin livrera un
escadron de 14 blindés lourds l'objectif
étant d'envoyer une seconde compagnie au
plus vite
volody mirzelenski s'est dit sincèrement
reconnaissant même si l'assuré ces
derniers jours en avoir besoin de
centaines pour repousser les forces
russes
autre annonce du chancelier il autorise
la dizaine de pays qui possèdent des
chars léopards 2 à les fournir à Kiev
propos notamment salué par la Pologne
qu'il avait fait officiellement la
demande l'Allemagne qui va aussi
rapidement former sur son sol des
soldats Ukrainiens à l'utilisation de
ces blindés lourds si Olaf Scholl
césitait jusque-là à donner ce double
feu vert c'est qu'il est soucieux
d'éviter une escalade avec Moscou mais
ces derniers jours la pression était
devenue trop forte au sein de la
coalition gouvernementale et de la part
des alliés la Russie n'a pas tardé à
réagir à l'annonce allemande par la voix
de son ambassadeur à Berlin elle dénonce
une décision extrêmement dangereuse qui
selon elle va amener le conflit vers un
nouveau niveau de confrontation
une rhétorique habituelle depuis le
début de la guerre destiné à faire
hésiter les pays alliés au moment de
fournir davantage d'armement acquies